You’ve all seen that show.
Good guy reads the paint splatter on the wall,
tests the DNA, and bags the killer all within
50 minutes.
But how much of that is close to real life?
Hey future serial killers,
We all think that’s how solving crimes works
right?
The killer is an idiot who leaves minuscule
traces of his DNA all over the place and crime
scene investigators use the latest tech to
catch the bad guy.
While this happens in Hollywood, it’s not
reality.
And unfortunately, many people can’t tell
the difference.
This is what’s called the CSI effect.
It’s when these shows influence how the
administration of justice plays out.
Many jurors expect and demand that crimes
be solved by super tech that doesn’t really
exist.
But through a mix of old and new techniques
science is helps solve even the most heinous
of crimes.
You might be surprised how much you can tell
from a drop of blood.
When you get your blood drawn at the doctor’s
and shipped off to be tested, a lot can be
revealed.
From your blood cell count, your glucose and
cholesterol levels, tests can tell if you
have certain diseases or viruses.
It can even tell you your biological age,
not just your chronological age, according
to a study published in the journal Nature.
Things like bad diet, low exercise and stress
can make your body’s cells appear older
than how many trips around the sun you’ve
taken.
But that’s blood collected in a precise,
clinical way, blood stains on hotel room carpet…
different story.
Blood can tell a story of a crime.
Blood spatter allows investigators to recreate
the events that unfolded.
It’s actually an old science, the first
systematic study of bloodstains was published
at the University of Vienna in 1895, titled
“On the formation, form, direction and spreading
of blood stains resulting in blunt trauma
at the head”.
But over the decades, it’s gotten much more
advanced.
The field uses a mix of math and science to
figure out what happened.
According to the book “Principles of Bloodstain
Pattern Analysis” bloodstains can be divided
into three categories: passive/gravity, spatter
and altered.
Passive is like it sounds, like blood pooling
under a victim.
Spatter on the other hand, well the type of
blood spatter can sometimes tell where an
injury was.
Expirated bloodstain patterns comes from more
“natural” occurrences like by breathing,
spitting and coughing up blood.
You can find bubbles in these stains from
air pockets and it might be a lighter color
from being diluted from saliva.
Altered means, like you would expect, that
the stain has been altered in some way, like
an object being dragged across it or an attempt
at a clean up.
According to a study in SIAK-Journal - the
Journal for Police Science and Practice, impact
spatter patterns indicates something traumatic,
like a gunshot, blunt force trauma, or from
machinery.
The blood drops extend outward from a point
in direct lines.
If it’s an impact spatter, it’s very likely
that there was more than one blow, as the
first blow never spreads much blood.
But the effectiveness of such analyses are
really varied.
Depending the amount of blood, a vague idea
of a weapon, whether is was blunt or sharp
or a bullet can be determined.
The location and pattern of the blood can
give investigators an idea of angle, velocity,
and trajectory of the blood.
By analyzing these kinds of patterns, they
get an idea of how hard the force of impact
was or what angle the attack came from.
And of course if there’s enough blood, you
can even find out someone’s identity.
DNA analysis is considered the “gold standard”
of crime scene investigation reliability.
But it took awhile for that technology advance.
In the 70’s, the only thing they could tell
was which type of blood it was.
Which depending on the type could narrow the
suspects down to 4 to 49% of the population.
Now using polymerase chain reaction, PCR technique,
which takes a small piece of DNA and multiplies
it hundreds of times so it’s easier to “see’”
and analyze.
After PCR, DNA then goes through a process
called gel electrophoresis which makes it
easy to compare DNA samples.
You’ve probably seen these on TV or maybe
in your own biology lab.
The gels looks like columns with little lines
that trap certain lengths of DNA fragments
in different sections.
By comparing how these lines match up to known
or unknown other known, researchers can either
remove someone as a suspect or nail the sucker
down.
While blood can tell the story of a crime
scene, the right domain name will tell yours.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
Of course if evidence of the crime is wiped
away with bleach, you’re screwed.
Or are you?
To find out how blood can make a crime scene
light up like the night sky, check out this
video right here.